Mẹ thân xong, chuyên bài của A, in giờ khởi hàng từ Amida Bát, ở Nộ, đi luôn đôn của anh, đã gặp ngãn
chỉ vài phút sau khi các cạnh, đâm xong khu dân cờ, khiến nhất hai chăm tri mến người thì mạch,
trong đào con nhiều sinh viên và người dân dì mạch đất. Tuy nhiên, một hàng khác ngồi tại vì chỉ
mới một án, đám máy mắn sống sống, chờ thành tâm điểm chú ý trong thảm hã này. Ngoài đa nông,
tên Rà Mà, của tịch anh, đang chín đường trở về luôn đôn sau chuyên thăm gia đình. Ghiến ngồi của anh,
tên Rà Mà, của mình một án, năm 1 đầu hàng phụ thân, đình cờ thói điểm vi trước bên trảm bài. Theo có hoi
của môi, bày tảm bày, tảm, Dreamliner, đây là khu vật có thể hỗ trợ thói điểm nhắn trong nếu tảm đạn
sửa ra. Sau khi tình dậy trong đống đổ nát, Rà Mà sẽ kể lại anh đã thấy tí tình, năm
gồn ngăn, khoảng loạt đứng dậy rồi được người dân hỗ trợ được đi cất cứu.
Sự giống sốt của anh, khách về mình một án chẳng gợp, những những cờ chứ đó, bốn cho rằng
hành khách môi đối mề bài của tỉ lệ sống cao hơn khi tài nạn sử ra. Các phần tích giới liệu từ Mỹ và anh cho thấy
phần đôi thường chỉ uống ít tả đồng hơn phần đầu. Tuy nhiên, nhiều trường hậm hỏi lệ từng sử ra,
cho thấy vị chính hồi không phải là yếu tổ duy nhất quy định sự sống cơm.
Các chuyên sàng không khẩm định, yêu tố thành chốt là tình hỗng cờ thề của buồn tài nạn, nhưng gấp dơ,
tâm độ vào chạm, cấu chút mấy bài biện vường xa xao và khoảng cách đến cờ thói tìm.
Trong buồn dơ mấy bài tãn đổ lần này, phần đầu mấy bài vẫn còn quyền bệnh phần nào và vị chỉ mời một
an gần cờ thói tốt dù vành khách kịp thời thất khỏi đám trái. Cô bằng không liên bằng Mỹ,
e và và tất chuyên sàng nhiều lần nhấn mạnh, không có chống hồi nào tự đối ăn bản chiếm mấy bài.
Trong các tình hôn khẩn cấp, thời gian phản lữ và vị chỉ thói tìm, nâng như liệu tổ quy định.